this first one here that i've lined up
for you is a
it's basically a summary let me put
something in the screen over here it's
basically like a collection of sound
bites
uh on how the media outside of canada
has been portraying this let me just
pull this back over here if you guys
can't hear this in the chat just just
let me know and i'll i'll turn it up a
little bit more but just watch this it's
a quick minute and change
versus truckers in a battle over
canada's coveted vaccine mandate
blackface himself justin trudeau oh he's
got black face on interesting what an
embarrassing virtue signaling imposter
most people are trying to send you a
message i have a message for you prime
minister you're a disgrace justin
trudeau in particular who has got to be
the most pathetic leader in the world
currently in hiding apparently
that's um
that's basically cowboys there running
running their horses through the
downtown streets of ottawa in the world
currently in hiding apparently he fled
do you know why because the white knight
of democracy could not
this indian [ __ ] calls him the white
knight of democracy
that's awesome handle a protest he fled
the city
trudeau evacuated his official residence
and hid in an undisclosed location he is
still cowering there tonight he looks
like he wet his pants
so that
that scene there is what you know he's
calling the fringe minority um and it's
huge like i've like i've watched a
number of on location videos
um and there's crowds some people are
saying
in the in the tens of thousands in some
areas um they're not small and they're
very peaceful they're just you know
they're just there to have a good time
wave a flag and make a position i'm
going to show you some other stuff
that's been going on as well
um and how the locals have been dealt
with it but the feds are apparently
planting moles to
engineer havoc kind of like what
happened in the u.s uh last january but
let's keep playing this check it out i
have not seen
any barbarians with tiki torches and
pitchforks these seem like reasonable
people that just want to work hard
working good people when justin trudeau
was locked down wherever he was locked
down along with the rest of the
political class these people kept
working the canadian truckers are heroes
they are patriots and they are marching
for your freedom and for my freedom they
are those truck drivers that god blessed
them they're defending canada but
they're defending america as well that
is that is courage on display it's
pretty inspirational it's a fight for
freedom it's powerful get your ass out
of your house and go visit the truckers
and hear them out
and then you should start listening to
them because they make more sense than
you do you're just a hypocrite wavy hair
or not
you're just a hypocrite wavy hair or not
she says
yeah it's um
that's just one of the pieces i'm going
to give you guys some more
mackin says i left canada two days
before travel mandates i'm coming back
in the beginning of march we can't wait
to get that ticket for not going to
quarantine
yeah
yeah it's it's man it's freaking weird
out there
um so here's another clip uh sorry let
me just remove this over here stop
screen i don't think i need to play any
of these so i don't need audio
share screen
window let's do it that way
so here's another uh news piece
um in the star apparently
ottawa police are warning truckers to
end the protest or face arrest the
federal government made it clear it's
not prepared to invoke emergency power
to take on the reigns of the crisis blah
blah blah
there's been talk about the uh federal
government bringing in the military
using the rcmp which is a royal canadian
mounted police which is a federal
level of policing um but it looks like
the ottawa local police are now warning
um the truckers and the protesters up
there to leave or face arrest and i'll
say this so if you're a police officer
in ottawa
this is where you need to take a stand
okay
if you guys want this to end i mean
they've been calling truck drivers
or sorry the uh the heavy tow truck
drivers
to come in and remove the trucks and the
heavy tow truck drivers and these people
are their customers obviously have
declined they said no we're not going to
get involved you guys are on your own so
they tried that first they said you know
let's call in these big ass heavy rigs
to tow the 18 wheelers and the rigs out
and um you know let's get them out of
the way um the tow truck driver said no
we're not doing it good for them
so now the cops
are
starting to get pushed and i'm going to
show you some of the clips on what the
cops are doing up there
to kind of exemplify it but now the cops
are apparently threatening to end it or
arrest the protesters
police officers
this is where you need to take a stand
you need to decide
if
doing this job is worth it
if it was me
keep keep your informed keep your gun
take it all pound sand i'd walk away
some people don't have that power but
man
don't do it do not do it this is where
you have an opportunity to do the right
thing
and just say no to this [ __ ]
uh let's see what else we got up here
did we do okay we did that one let's do
this one
oh this one i got to get audio on so
this is a clip of
planted moles
which have been designed to engineer
havoc now
i saw this two weeks ago it was a two
weeks ago roughly where they had a guy
marching amongst the protesters with a
confederate flag and i think a swastika
painted into the middle of it
interestingly there was a photographer
who they captured following this guy
who also looks very very similar to
justin trudeau's personal photographer
there's images of that out there you can
go look it up it's it's actually on my
timeline from two weeks ago the problem
is twitter is so busy for me i'd have a
hard time digging through it to find it
but it's there
um this is a more recent one where there
is another um what appears to be a fed
planted mole who was trying to engineer
havoc on the crowd and encourage them to
rush the capital if not mistaken let me
just take the um audio on that and share
it give me a second here
stop screen share this is what's
happening on the ground like there is no
violence there is no
um
bad [ __ ] going down uh it's this one
over here
there's no misogyny there's no racism
there's no islamophobia as trudeau has
been purporting
uh in his random uh
little little uh pitches that he's been
doing let me just try to make this a
little bit bigger so you guys can get a
screen on it because i think he shows
the
all right so let's play this let me know
if you guys can't hear this are you
chilling
chilling like a villain
oh hey yo did i talk to you yesterday
yeah you want to say something again
what else am i going to say we're
expecting uh
we just caught an ark yeah we're a fed
oh
what happened there
try that again sorry about that
oh hey yo did i talk to you yesterday
yeah you want to say something again
what else am i going to say we're
expecting uh
we just caught an arc yeah we're a fed
he was uh trying to get us to
overrun the parliament really yeah so we
pulling the [ __ ] off yeah yeah we hit
him on camera huh get him on camera we
did it we got him got a picture of him
you want to show him oh yeah show the
whole world what he looks like yeah we
got people watching man
take a look at these trucks guys
love it man all right are there are some
of them here in ottawa
yeah all right boys this is the guy that
you guys have to watch out for he's a
[ __ ] bed hold on let me get the zoom
there you go guys he'll try to get you
guys to [ __ ] overrun the government
and [ __ ] blah blah you'll try and say
anything that he can you have a [ __ ]
microphone in a scarf that i've seen
yourself but he's trying to entrap you
exactly he's working with them we tried
to report to the cops and the cops
didn't even get our information nothing
they said okay no problem i just got a
picture that was dead
so
careful don't hurt him but be beware
guys beware listen
to all those guys who are thinking we
should be doing something worse than
just sitting around let me explain
something to you the reason why we're
taking [ __ ] slow
and the reason why we're doing
everything in peace is to show the whole
world how corrupt this government really
is yeah they tried to [ __ ] us with the
news didn't succeed they tried to [ __ ]
us with the feds didn't succeed the more
more time goes on
the more and more they're digging their
own [ __ ] ground digging their own
ground yeah so so far everybody saw that
this place was peaceful it's gonna be
peaceful yeah the reason why is because
you guys are gonna keep trying to do
some [ __ ] and the whole world's gonna
see how [ __ ] corrupt you guys really
are yeah so amen man that's what we're
trying to stop god bless
there you go
so they're running into
what
what appear to be fed planted moles that
are trying to engineer havoc amongst the
crowd and encourage them to be to
misbehave
and canadians are too nice of that we're
way too polite we're way too nice for
that kind of stuff um you know we've
seen it happen before
but but
for the entirety
there's been no violence there's been no
damage to property in fact we've seen
we've seen people clean up the streets
like i've seen images and i didn't put
it in here but i've seen images and
videos of like people actually like
cleaning up garbage and um there was a
flag draped around a statue in ottawa of
terry fox if you don't know who terry
fox was
uh he was a very public figure when i
was a kitty i think he had cancer if i'm
not mistaken and he and his deal was to
run across canada raise money for
cancer treatment and he died before he
got to
um the end of his uh journey so they
made a statue of him uh in downtown
ottawa so what the
truckers did was they put a uh flag
around his neck kind of like a cape and
he had a
sign in his hand that just said and the
mandates uh later on that day they
cleaned up the statue and they removed
everything and they tied it up and all
that sort of stuff like that's how
they're treating it like they're not
spray painting anything they're not
destroying monuments they're not tearing
down statues or anything like that like
we've seen in the past over the last
couple years with the people that throw
hissy fits this is not a hissy fit this
is grown ass adults mostly men taking a
stand for what's right
uh let's see what else we got here again
you know great example of playing to win
right
um
oh here's a quick note i don't put
something on the screen i'll just read
it uh government gives uh pharma
billions to develop its product
gives pharma immunity gives pharma or
sorry buys farmers product
mandates
pharma's product promotes pharma's
product and then silences criticism and
prevents uh transparency of pharma's
product
and then it closes with saying i miss
that course in business school
yeah
um here's another one
so this is what the cops are now doing
in ottawa let's throw this in the stream
uh let me see if there's audio on this i
don't think there's audio
yeah there is audio hold on a sec
let me just pause this because i gotta
remove and then add the audio to it
share screen
tab
and here it is share audio tab
okay so this is
a clip somebody posted
15 hours ago
ottawa police are confiscating firewood
from the freedom convoy so obviously
it's cold it's february in canada it's
probably
minus
15 to 20 some nights uh downtown ottawa
even colder and you know some nights if
there's no cloud cover so of course you
know they've got to stay warm um so
firewood is essential the police are
confiscating firewood
from the convoy
since when was it illegal to possess
wood
look at these guys
[Music]
you know the cops are taking the wood
the barrels
they're not even caught like saying
shame to them or anything like that
they're just letting them do it that's
how nice canadians are
right
what's the next one here we got
oh this is good this is the this is the
gas can fiasco this is something else
that they're probably not putting out on
um
general mainstream media again you know
this is this is people using their cell
phones to report what's happening which
to me is a far more reliable source than
sitting down and clicking your box and
watching
uh canadian news which by the way is
owned by the federal government okay for
those of you that don't know
they have subsidized and bailed out the
news media the federal news media
um and they basically
tell them what to say which is why you
won't see any of this stuff on
mainstream let me add this next one over
here this probably has audio so i gotta
give me a second here stop screen
share
tab
and here it is your audio tab
so this
this clip here that i'm going to play
for you
are
how people are responding to support the
truckers the the police have said to
uh people that you can't bring
fuel canisters into the trucks i don't
know what the uh trucks need maybe they
got to run their diesel engines every
day just to heat up the cabin i'm sure
the truckers are sleeping you know in
the
bed that's in the back of most of them
so
they've been bringing fuel to them but
the police started to confiscate the
fuel to make it difficult
so
what these supporters have now done is
they got together and said all right
everybody meet at this corner
and bring a fuel canister some will be
filled with fuel some will be empty some
might have water in them they're not
going to arrest us all there's going to
be way too many of us so watch this
this is awesome
this is how creative they are like this
is how they're trolling them look at
this [ __ ]
look at all these people there's and it
keeps going back and back look at them
all
carrying carrying jerry cans
to the truckers
this is
awesome is so good
no masks no standing on dots
no cowardly stuff it's just hey you know
let's give these guys some support
you get the point right
you